In September, documents leaked to the media by a former Facebook employee revealed that the company's internal research had found that its apps could be harmful for teens, particularly for teenage girls' mental health. The headlines about toxic social media seem to confirm parents' worst fears about the effects of all the time that kids are spending online. Recent surveys have found that 95% of U.S. teens have a smartphone or access to one, and more than 80% have at least one social media, on Instagram, Snapchat, TikTok, Facebook, or other sites. But psychologist's research has suggested that there are nuanced answers to the questions surrounding how all this social media use is affecting teens' health and well-being. For instance, is there such a thing as healthy social media use for teens? And if so, what does that look like?
今年9月，前Facebook员工向媒体泄露的文件显示，该公司的内部研究发现，其应用可能对青少年造成危害，特别是对少女的心理健康。有关毒性社交媒体的头条新闻似乎证实了父母对孩子们上网时间的各种影响的最坏担忧。最近的调查发现，95%的美国青少年拥有智能手机或能够使用智能手机，其中80%以上至少拥有一个社交媒体账号，如Instagram、Snapchat、TikTok、Facebook或其他网站。但心理学家的研究表明，对于所有这些社交媒体的使用如何影响青少年的健康和福祉这一问题，有着微妙的答案。例如，是否存在适合青少年的健康社交媒体使用这回事？如果是的话，它是什么样子的？
Does social media cause depression and anxiety? Or, conversely, can it be a source of social and emotional support for kids? Do teens understand that? routines understand how social media algorithms work and why they see the content that they do online. Why does that matter? And what can parents, educators, and others do to maximize the benefits and minimize the potential harms of social media? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
社交媒体会导致抑郁和焦虑吗？或者相反，它能成为孩子们社交和情感支持的来源吗？青少年明白这一点吗？日常生活中，他们理解社交媒体算法是如何工作的以及为什么他们在网上看到特定的内容吗？为什么这很重要？父母、教育工作者和其他人可以做些什么来最大化社交媒体的好处并最小化潜在的危害？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Linda Charmarmarmeran, a senior research. scientist and director of the youth media and well-being research lab at the Wellesley Centers for Women. She studies young people's social media use and is conducting a three-year National Institutes of Health-funded study to follow middle school students and their parents during this critical developmental period. She's looking at how social technologies, including smartphones, social media, YouTube, and gaming affect kids' health and well-being in the longer term. She's published dozens of journal articles and seven book chapters and has been widely quoted in the media offering advice to parents, educators,
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是琳达·查马曼雷（Linda Charmaraman）博士，她是韦尔斯利妇女中心（Wellesley Centers for Women）的资深研究科学家兼青年媒体与福祉研究实验室主任。她研究年轻人的社交媒体使用情况，目前正在进行一项由美国国立卫生研究院（National Institutes of Health）资助的为期三年的研究，在这一关键的发展时期追踪初中生及其父母。她正在研究智能手机、社交媒体、YouTube和游戏等社交技术如何对儿童的长期健康和福祉产生影响。她发表了数十篇期刊文章和七章书籍章节，并在媒体上被广泛引用，为父母、教育工作者、
policymakers, and others. Thank you for joining us today. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with the Facebook documents leak since that's been such a big news story. The headline was that Facebook's own research found that its platforms, particularly Instagram, could be harmful to teens' mental health. Facebook's research found associations with anxiety, depression, body image issues, and even suicidal thoughts. Were you surprised by these findings and do they square with what you and other researchers have found? I'm so glad you mentioned that study
决策者和其他人提供建议。感谢您今天加入我们。非常感谢邀请我。让我们从Facebook的文件泄露开始，因为这是一个很大的新闻故事。头条新闻是Facebook自己的研究发现，其平台，特别是Instagram，可能对青少年的心理健康有害。Facebook的研究发现这与焦虑、抑郁、身体形象问题甚至自杀倾向有关。你对这些发现感到惊讶吗？它们与你和其他研究人员的发现相符吗？我很高兴你提到这项研究
because it has definitely been going around in my circles. And let me just say the first answer to your question is no, I'm not surprised because there's been hundreds of studies about social media platforms in general that have differential sort of impacts on young people depending on how they use it. And so I'm not surprised that there's some kind of data coming from their internal sources that shows some of the harm that can be found. Other studies have found similar findings.
因为它绝对在我的圈子里流传。让我先说对你问题的第一个回答是，不，我并不感到惊讶，因为关于社交媒体平台总体上有数百项研究，根据年轻人的使用方式，它们对年轻人有着不同种类的影响。因此，我不惊讶有某种来自他们内部的数据显示出可以被发现的某种危害。其他研究也发现了类似的结果。
You know, in fact, one of our body image-related papers about teenage girls and boys, you know, have found similar things about, you know, about 20-30 percent of them have some kind of social media-related body dissatisfaction resulting in it and that there are celebrities. that they friend that can exacerbate some of those issues. And so the point I wanted to make about that is that this research is out there, peer-reviewed in academic journals, and it isn't until there's a leak in the press, you know, that gets wind of this, that it's suddenly national news. It's on people's news feeds all the time, even though this is not peer-reviewed data and it's not nationally representative.
你知道，事实上，我们关于少女和少年的身体形象相关论文之一，发现了一些类似的事情，大约20%到30%的人因此产生了某种与社交媒体相关的身体不满，而且他们加为好友的名人会加剧其中的一些问题。因此，我想指出的是，这项研究已经存在，并在学术期刊上经过同行评审，直到媒体出现泄露，引起了人们的注意，它才突然成为全国新闻。它一直出现在人们的新闻动态中，尽管这不是经过同行评审的数据，也不是全国代表性的数据。
It's actually based on pretty small samples. So the national attention it's getting, I think it's somehow misdirecting. What should be really the point of it is that we need to increase our attention on social media literacy programming in the schools and parental guidance and monitoring and empowering youth to use it in more positive ways without relying on an industry or a product to keep them safe. So how are teens using social media these days and what sites are they on? I mean, we all hear that Facebook is for old people now. So where do young people congregate online and how do social technologies fit into their everyday lives?
它实际上基于相当小的样本。所以我认为它获得的全国关注在某种程度上有些误导。真正应该关注的重点是，我们需要加大对学校社交媒体素养规划、父母指导和监控的关注，并赋能年轻人以更积极的方式使用它，而不依赖于某个行业或产品来保证他们的安全。那么，现在青少年是如何使用社交媒体的？他们都在哪些网站上？我的意思是，我们都听说Facebook现在是老年人用的。那么年轻人都在网上哪里聚集，社交技术又是如何融入他们的日常生活的？
Yes, yes. Well, I am specializing in middle school youth, so 11 to 15 year olds. And the ones that are in my study of over about 1,500 youth that I'm following over time, in their top 10 sites, Facebook doesn't even crack top. top 10, Instagram is number two. So YouTube is number one and then Instagram and then TikTok and then Snapchat. So they're all very close together though, you know, about 70% of them are on, you know, Instagram, Snapchat, TikTok. And they definitely are interacting in ways that are being more and more common nowadays to use it as not just connection, but for also raising awareness of social issues that they care about. So there's ways that youth are using it that might not be what
是的，是的。嗯，我专注于初中青年，也就是11到15岁的孩子。在我的大约1500名我长期追踪的青年研究中，在前10大网站中，Facebook甚至没有排进前10名，Instagram排名第二。YouTube排名第一，然后是Instagram，然后是TikTok，然后是Snapchat。不过它们都非常接近，大约70%的人在使用Instagram、Snapchat、TikTok。他们绝对在以越来越普遍的方式进行互动，不仅将其用作联系的手段，还用来提高对他们关心的社会问题的认识。因此，年轻人使用它的方式可能不是
other generations might imagine them using it for. You know, there's a lot of narrative out there that it's a lot of online drama, which there is. There are online drama, you know, instances, of course, and there's a lot of cyberbullying. There's a lot of media headlines about all the negative things that can go wrong, the worst-case scenarios. But the Pew Research Center, in a national representative sample, found that only about 20-something percent, you know, have really negative kind of experiences on social media, but mostly, almost 80% of people have primarily positive and connecting experiences and socially supportive experiences. And so what I'm hoping for knowing about this data and knowing what kids are actually
其他世代可能想象的用途。你知道，外面有很多说法认为有很多网络戏剧，确实有。当然有网络戏剧的例子，还有很多网络霸凌。有很多关于所有可能出错的负面事情、最坏情况的媒体头条。但皮尤研究中心（Pew Research Center）在一个全国代表性样本中发现，只有大约百分之二十几的人在社交媒体上有非常负面的经历，但大多数人，将近80%的人主要有积极的、连接的和提供社会支持的经历。因此，我希望了解这些数据并了解孩子们在这些网站上实际
doing on these sites is that we support the positive, you know, interactions and also help prevent some of the negative, but knowing that all of it is happening, not just a negative. But for that 20% it's pretty important. I mean, they could be having some issues, for example, with teenage girls around body image. Are you seeing big gender differences in the way that young people use social media and the effects that it can have? Yes, definitely some gender differences. You can probably see it in your own households out there where the boys are more gravitating towards games and sites like Discord and Twitch and YouTube and watching videos of other gamers, you know. And girls are a lot more about the image-based platform.
做的事情是，我们支持积极的互动，同时也帮助防止一些负面的互动，但要知道所有这些都在发生，而不仅仅是负面的一面。但对于那20%的人来说，这非常重要。我的意思是，他们可能会遇到一些问题，例如青少年少女的身体形象问题。你是否看到年轻人使用社交媒体的方式以及它可能产生的影响存在巨大的性别差异？是的，肯定存在一些性别差异。你可能在你们自己的家庭中也能看到这一点，男孩更倾向于游戏和Discord、Twitch和YouTube等网站，并观看其他游戏玩家的视频。
you know, like Instagram and Snapchat and where you can use filters and kind of create this other, you know, vision of themselves. Girls are more likely to use Pinterest, you know, than boys. So there's definitely gender differences that are seen on offline, you know, instances as well where boys just gravitate towards certain activities more than girls. And in terms of the negative effects, are there more negative effects for girls or boys or is it kind of evenly distributed? Yes.
而女孩则更多地关注基于图像的平台，像Instagram和Snapchat，在这里你可以使用过滤器并创造另一种对自己的愿景。女孩比男孩更有可能使用Pinterest。因此，线下也可以看到明显的性别差异，男孩就是比女孩更倾向于某些活动。至于负面影响，对女孩还是男孩的负面影响更大，还是说它分布得比较均匀？是的。
It really depends on what construct your... you're interested in looking at. Like, for instance, for body image, you know, girls report are socially groomed to be able to report that they experience that more. I'd say it is a thing happening in boys, but they're not socially groomed to admit it as much, I would venture to guess. But it does happen in boys. And for girls, especially, since there's such a huge societal preoccupation about
这真的取决于你感兴趣的研究结构是什么。例如，对于身体形象，女孩报告并被社会化训练得能够报告她们更多地体验到这一点。我想说这在男孩身上也会发生，但我敢冒险猜测，他们没有受到同样的社会化训练来承认这一点。但这确实发生在男孩身上。特别是对于女孩，因为社会对
girls' bodies and needing to comment about girls' bodies and to adhere to perfect beauty ideals that girls have much more than boys in a lot of cases. And so there's a lot more just being self-conscious about those things, the images you put up and how it relates to your social status, online and offline. So girls have been shown to maybe have a little bit more of a tendency to be socially comparing themselves to other people and perhaps to other girls. And perhaps to other girls, so not just their bodies, but just in general. And when you have that sort of vulnerability, it often affects your self-esteem and how you feel about yourself. And so it's all connected in a way. So it could be that they already bringing that vulnerability to how they use platforms. And that's
女孩的身体有着巨大的全社会关注，需要对女孩的身体进行评论，并且要符合女孩在许多情况下比男孩多得多的完美美学理想。因此，对于这些事情，对于你发布的图像以及它如何与你的线上和线下社会地位相关，会有更多的自我意识。因此，事实证明，女孩可能稍微倾向于将自己与其他人进行社会比较，也许与其他女孩进行比较。也许与其他女孩进行比较，所以不仅是她们的身体，而且是一般的比较。当你有了这种脆弱性时，它通常会影响你的自尊以及你对自己的感觉。所以这一切在某种程度上都是相连的。因此，可能是他们已经将这种脆弱性带入了他们使用平台的方式中。这就是
why they go down a road that might be not as a happy road than the boys that might not be caring about the social comparisons and body comparisons. So a moment ago, you mentioned, cyberbullying, and I know that's gotten a lot of media coverage over the years, how common is it? Has it changed? Is it as frequent a concern among the kids you're dealing with? Yeah. That's a very interesting question because one of our latest papers, we're looking at subpopulations, specific groups of adolescents in which we're trying to figure out, are they more prone to being victimized by cyberbullying? You know, for instance, we had this paper about LGBTQ youth and how definitely the The dominant narrative in the past has been that LGBTQ youth are harassed a significantly greater frequency than their straight peers.
为什么他们可能会走上一条不像那些可能不关心社会比较和身体比较的男孩那样快乐的道路。那么刚才你提到了网络霸凌，我知道这些年来这受到了很多媒体报道，它有多普遍？它变了吗？在你们应对的孩子中，这是一个经常出现的担忧吗？是的。这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为在我们的一篇最新论文中，我们正在研究子群体，即特定的青少年群体，我们试图弄清楚，他们是否更容易成为网络霸凌的受害者？例如，我们有这篇关于LGBTQ青少年的论文，毫无疑问，
And in our latest research, we try to look into this community-based sample in which is representative of the communities and not just people who identify as LGBTQ youth. We compare them with straight youth and how they're experiencing cyberbullying. And they weren't significantly different in how they experienced cyberbullying, the frequency. It could just be that I'm also in a very liberal part of the country. I live in the Northeast where it's very progressive. However, it is really promising to hear that it might not be as much of the dominant narrative. Now, the narrative we found instead of the cyberbullying, which is what everybody wants to talk about,
过去的主流说法是，LGBTQ青年遭受骚扰的频率明显高于他们的异性恋同龄人。而在我们最新的研究中，我们试图研究这个基于社区的样本，它代表了社区，而不仅仅是那些自识别为LGBTQ青少年的群体。我们将他们与异性恋青年进行比较，看他们如何经历网络霸凌。他们在经历网络霸凌的频率上没有显著差异。这可能只是因为我也在一个国家的非常自由派的地区。我住在东北部，那里非常进步。然而，听到它可能不那么符合主流说法，确实很有希望。现在，我们发现取代网络霸凌（这是每个人都想谈论的）的说法，
is more about social isolation, that there's still a lot of social isolation with LGBT youth and not knowing who to talk to about their different identities and about the support they might need that maybe only online sources can get because of their geographic restrictions, you know. And so the narrative might want to be a little more broad than just peer-on-peer harassment. It could be that there's other things going on in different vulnerable youth's lives in which social media could play a role in. So it sounds like there might be something positive then, at least for the LGBTQ kids in social media, that maybe gives them an opportunity to see. examples of how their lives might turn out or connect with other LGBTQ kids.
更多的是关于社会孤立，LGBT青年仍然存在很多社会孤立，不知道该跟谁谈论他们的不同身份，以及他们可能需要的支持，由于地理限制，这些支持可能只有在线资源才能获得。因此，这种说法可能需要更广泛一些，而不仅仅是同龄人之间的骚扰。可能是不同脆弱青年的生活中还发生了其他事情，社交媒体在其中发挥了作用。所以听起来社交媒体可能存在积极的一面，至少对于LGBTQ孩子来说，也许这让他们有机会看到
Is that what you're saying? Yes, and some sites are a lot more amenable and more open and receptive and even celebratory. You know, for instance, Tumblr has been a site that the LGBTQ community has cited as, you know, even back 10 years ago, Tumblr was something that was very open and receptive. Although there are some algorithms that recently called into place, some of the censoring that was happening based on certain keywords. But overall, you know, even though Tumblr has lost sort of popularity in the general public sphere, in our recent surveys, even just in fall 2020, that youth, LGBT youth, in this age range of 11 to 15,
他们的生活可能会变成什么样的例子，或者与其他LGBTQ孩子建立联系。这就是你所说的吗？是的，有些网站更加顺应、开放、接纳甚至庆祝。例如，Tumblr一直是LGBTQ社区提到的一个网站，甚至在10年前，Tumblr也是一个非常开放和接纳的平台。尽管最近有一些算法针对某些关键字实施了审查。但总体而言，尽管Tumblr在公众领域失去了普及度，但在我们最近的调查中，甚至在2020年秋季，11到15岁这个年龄段的
are still using Tumblr and still finding it to be a safe space for them to explore their identities. And it's just wonderful to know that those things don't come and go as easily as, people think of as social media sites being fads. Are some of these sites inherently riskier for teens than others? I mean, like TikTok where you see kids all the time who are out making videos of themselves. Are they doing things that might be risky? I mean, kids will always do things that are risky and crazy. But are there some sites that are more perilous for kids of this age?
LGBT青年仍在使用Tumblr，并仍然发现它是他们探索自己身份的安全空间。很高兴知道这些事情不会像人们认为社交媒体网站是潮流那样轻易来去。其中一些网站对青少年来说本质上比其他网站风险更高吗？我的意思是，比如TikTok，你经常看到孩子们在外面制作自己的视频。他们在做可能有风险的事情吗？我的意思是，孩子们总是会做一些有风险和疯狂的事情。但对于这个年龄段的孩子来说，有些网站更危险吗？
I would say it's not the site per se, but certain sites have features in which if users know about those features and how to manipulate those features for sort of, you know, not innocent purposes, then then that's when you sort of get into the risky categories. You know, the sites that the parents are less familiar with, you know, like for instance, TikTok, you know, probably parents are less familiar with that than Facebook. So they don't know all the ways that they can kind of hide their identities or how create other accounts in which the parents don't monitor or they don't know the existence of so they can kind of, you know, do wacky things that they probably wouldn't want their parents to know about, you know.
我想说这本身并不是网站的问题，而是某些网站具有某些功能，如果用户了解这些功能以及如何为了某种（你知道的）非纯粹目的操纵这些功能，那么你就会进入风险类别。你知道，父母不太熟悉的网站，例如TikTok，父母可能对它的熟悉程度不如Facebook。因此，他们不知道孩子们隐藏身份或创建其他父母监控不到或不知道其存在的账户的所有方式，这样他们就可以做一些他们可能不想让父母知道的古怪事情。
And so it's it's not exactly about the site per se. It's about how the users find ways to not be, you know, under surveillance of the adults that might judge that, you know, their grandma, they don't want the grandma to see that, TikTok, but it's okay, you know, their inside friends will have a laugh over that particular video. But the grandma will need to see this other side of them. So a lot of parents want to know at what age is it okay for kids to get a smartphone or a social media account? What would you tell them? How young is too young for social media? That's a great question.
所以这并不完全关乎网站本身。这关乎用户如何找到不被可能评判他们的成年人（他们可能不想让奶奶看到那个TikTok，但没关系，他们的死党会对那个特定的视频哈哈大笑）监视的方法。但是奶奶不需要看到他们这一面。因此，很多父母想知道，孩子在什么年龄可以拥有一部智能手机或社交媒体账号？你会对他们说些什么？多小才算太小而不能使用社交媒体？这是一个很好的问题。
Very common concern, I have to say. The average age of getting a smartphone in the U.S. is, I think, 10.3, the last I saw. And that's pretty young. I mean, that's like fourth grade. I have a fourth grader. And I don't think that she's quite. ready for it. But there's a lot of reasons why people get a smartphone. You know, sometimes it's very instrumental to just, you know, where are they at? How do I get you a ride? You know, how do I
这是一个非常普遍的担忧，我必须说。我看到的最新数据显示，美国拥有智能手机的平均年龄是10.3岁。这相当小。我的意思是，这就像四年级。我有一个四年级的孩子。我认为她还不是很
pick you up? You know, very basic kind of ways to communicate with your family when you're not right next to each other all the time. I would say that it really depends on the family and the kid and the use of the phone because in our research, we found that most of the time when you look at the general trajectory of how people start getting initiated into their first social media sites is because they first got that phone. So what do you think is going to happen next when you get the phone? They're not going to just be on, you know, Google, you know, searching Google and searching, being on YouTube. They're going to find out that their friends are all on these other sites and they're going to start downloading things. And so usually about a year later, they're on
准备好。但人们拥有智能手机有很多原因。你知道，有时这非常具有工具性，只是为了知道他们在哪里？我怎么帮你叫车？你知道，我怎么
at least one or two and then two years later, they're on three, four, five different sites, you know, because that's just the natural progression of the peer kind of influence and, you know, if their school site has a huge peer pressure to have everybody on TikTok, then it's very likely that your kid is going to be pressured into it. So it depends on the peer group. We have some research that we're doing on actually the age of initiation and if it makes a difference in the long run. And we are finding that the younger that they are initiating,
接你？当你不能一直彼此挨着时，这是一种与家人沟通的非常基础的方式。我想说这 realmente 取决于家庭、孩子和手机的使用，因为在我们的研究中，我们发现大多数时候，当你观察人们开始接触他们的第一个社交媒体网站的一般轨迹时，是因为他们首先得到了那部手机。所以你认为当你得到手机后接下来会发生什么？他们不会只是在谷歌上搜索，在YouTube上。他们会发现他们的朋友都在这些其他网站上，他们会开始下载东西。所以通常大约一年后，他们在使用
let's say, in terms of social media, and this is not smartphone, This is social media, and specifically Instagram and Snapchat. We wanted to look at these specifically because there's so many different ones out there. We want it to be very, very clear. Usually the younger that they are, the more likely they are to have more online harassment happen because they've been on it longer. They have more followers. You know, they have more chances for mean things happening online, more online drama.
至少一两个，两年后，他们在三、四个、五个不同的网站上，因为这只是同龄人影响的自然进展，如果他们的学校里有巨大的同龄人压力，要求每个人都在TikTok上，那么你的孩子很有可能会被强迫加入。所以这取决于同龄人群体。我们正在做一些关于起始年龄以及它在长期内是否有影响的研究。我们发现，他们越小开始接触，
There's a lot more behaviors in which they're doing things that are secretive that their parents don't know about. like maybe they're adding friends that the parents wouldn't approve of or they're adding sites that their parents wouldn't approve of. They are more likely to get a little bit fixated on the phone more, the younger than they are, because it's part of their everyday routine in a way. And although one positive thing about starting early on social media that we found in our studies is that they're more likely to know about the positive behaviors and socially supportive of behaviors that are a part of being a part of a community, a socially supportive community.
比方说，在社交媒体方面，这不是指智能手机，这是指社交媒体，特别是Instagram和Snapchat。我们希望专门研究这些，因为外面有太多不同的平台。我们希望非常非常清楚。通常他们越年轻，就越有可能发生网络骚扰，因为他们使用的时间更长了。他们有更多的粉丝。你知道，他们有更多机会在网上发生不好的事情，更多的网络戏剧。
So, but if you start much, much later, a lot of times there's a lot hesitancy to jump into community that you weren't a part of for a long time. And if you're like 14, there's so much that has happened on your peer, you know, social media sites and communities that you almost feel left out. You almost don't even know how to, how to jump in there. You didn't kind of grow some of those behaviors that will help you find the social support that you might need. Yeah, so there's a lot of pressure then to keep up. Absolutely. So there's been a growing public awareness in recent years of how social media algorithms control
有更多的行为表明他们在做父母不知道的秘密事情，比如他们可能会添加父母不会批准的朋友，或者他们添加父母不会批准的网站。他们越年轻，就越有可能对手机有点痴迷，因为这在某种程度上成了他们日常生活的一部分。尽管我们在研究中发现，很早开始使用社交媒体的一个积极之处在于，他们更有可能了解属于一个社区（一个提供社会支持的社区）一部分的积极行为和社会支持行为。
what we all see online and that these contribute to the political polarization and other societal problems that we're living with right now. In your research, have you found our kids and teens, maybe some of the older teens, aware of these algorithms? do they understand how they work and why they're seeing the stuff that they're seeing? I was actually surprised in some of the interview studies that I've done, how much middle schoolers both know and don't know. So they know that there are algorithms out there.
所以，但如果你开始得非常非常晚，很多时候你会对加入一个你长期不属于的社区感到犹豫。如果你14岁左右，你的同龄人社交媒体网站和社区已经发生了那么多事情，你会觉得自己被冷落了。你甚至不知道如何跳进去。你没有培养出能帮你找到你可能需要的社会支持的一些行为。是的，所以要跟上潮流有很大的压力。绝对是的。近年来，公众对社交媒体算法如何控制
They've heard that word. They know that there's content that's fed to them based on what they have already inputted. They kind of know that basic thing. And the thing that I think is really interesting is that most of the time they don't think there's anything wrong with that. They don't think there's anything creepy or sinister. or they think, wow, they know about me, how I'm famous, or I must be important that they want to know more about my habits.
我们在网上看到的内容的认识越来越高，这助长了政治极化和我们目前生活的其他社会问题。在你的研究中，你是否发现我们的孩子和青少年，也许是一些较大的青少年，意识到这些算法？他们了解它们是如何工作的以及为什么他们看到他们看到的东西吗？在我做的一些访谈研究中，我实际上对初中生了解和不了解的程度感到惊讶。所以他们知道外面有算法。
So I don't have any desire to shield what these companies want to know about me. So that's why there are protections against, you know, people from signing up from social media too young because, you know, you're supposed to be 13 due to, you know, federal requirements of COPA. And, you know, advertisers aren't supposed to find out information about people younger than 13. and for a good reason because of these kind of understandings and comments from middle schoolers that they're happy to give up their information. They're happy to keep their GPS on and show everybody where they're at and check in at all these locations
他们听说过这个词。他们知道根据他们已经输入的内容，有内容被喂给他们。他们某种程度上知道那个基础的事情。我认为非常有趣的是，大多数时候他们认为这没有任何问题。他们不认为这有什么诡异或邪恶。相反，他们认为，哇，他们了解我，我是多么有名，或者我一定很重要，所以他们想更多地了解我的习惯。
because it makes them feel famous and makes them feel, you know, seen. What do you tell parents then, I mean, some who might be listening to this discussion, you know, once we've posted it, about the best ways to encourage healthy social media use in kids? I mean, are there warning signs of potentially unhealthy social media use that parents should be looking out for? Yes, yes. There's the normative levels of addiction. And when you first start on a site or a game, you want to be on it all the time. So that's kind of like the normative level.
所以我没有任何欲望去屏蔽这些公司想了解我的信息。这就是为什么对保护人们过早注册社交媒体有规定的原因，因为根据COPA的联邦要求，你应该满13岁。广告商不应该获取比13岁更年轻的人的信息。
But if it goes into other areas of your life that you find they're missing meals, they are not as interested in hanging out with their friends offline anymore. They are losing sleep. They're not doing well in school because they are so hooked on whatever it is that screen is calling to them. That's when you might need to maybe ask your pediatrician, ask for a school counselor to check in, you know, ask if the teacher has any ideas in their class about how this might be affecting their schoolwork. And there's just a lot of ways in which parents could kind of know the signs because you will be the ones to know the signs before other people outside. the family, you know, and so if you're waiting for somebody else to say, your kid has a problem, you know, that, it's really going to be about your, you know, nuclear family unit that will really be on, on the same page, you know, you're actually seeing them day to day, how they've
这也是有充分理由的，因为初中生的这些理解和评论表明他们很乐意交出自己的信息。他们乐意保持GPS开启并向所有人展示他们的位置，并在所有这些地点签到，
changed over time, and you can kind of keep track of that. I think a lot of conversations about social media, and right from the time that you give them the first iPad, the first time you give them their first phone or let them use your phone, every time that they want to start up a new social media site, that's a great time to have another conversation. It's not just one talk, you know? It's multiple talks over many periods of time at each different age stages. You know, when you're about to start middle school for the first time, when you're about to start high school for the first time, what are the new rules that you might want to have in place? Because the rules that were good for a sixth grade are not going to be the same kind of
因为这让他们感到有名，让他们感到被看见。那么你对父母说些什么呢，我的意思是，有些可能在听这个讨论的人，一旦我们发布了它，关于鼓励孩子健康使用社交媒体的最佳方法是什么？我的意思是，是否存在潜在不健康社交媒体使用的警告信号，父母应该注意？是的，是的。有标准水平的成瘾。当你第一次开始使用一个网站或游戏时，你想一直玩它。所以这有点像标准水平。
rules you might have for a 10th grade. You know, when there's a lot more autonomy and a lot of things that are happening that the parents really have no idea about. But if you've instilled within the values that you want them to, to continue on in the cyberspace world, and you feel comfortable that they've been able to handle themselves, you know, in healthy ways and not get too over-concerned about the drama that's happening and know about the social media literacy behind it, fake news and all that kind of stuff, then you can feel that you've done your part in that journey of, you know, those discussions over a long period of time. So I'm wondering if there are ways to make these social media platforms safer for young people,
但如果它蔓延到你生活中的其他领域，你发现他们错过了正餐，他们不再对和线下的朋友出去玩感兴趣。他们在失眠。他们在学校表现不好，因为他们太沉迷于屏幕呼唤他们的任何东西。这时候你可能需要请教儿科医生，请学校辅导员来看看，询问老师在他们的课堂上是否有关于这可能如何影响他们学校作业的想法。有很多方法可以让父母了解这些迹象，因为你会是第一个知道这些迹象的人，比家庭以外的其他人更早，所以如果你在等待其他人说，你的孩子有问题，
particularly the middle schoolers that you're studying. I'm just wondering, how do we square the desire of the companies that make and provide these platforms to be successful with protecting young people from the potential harms. Well, one thing that probably should be done with much more rigor is to really monitor who are these people that are on your sites and how old are they really? Because, you know, technically there's only, you have to be 13, but it's so easy to bypass those age requirements and put in a fake birth date. And I think companies would, it would be in the best interest of their users if,
这实际上将关乎你们的核心家庭单元，你们会达成共识，你们实际上每天都在看着他们，看他们随着时间发生了怎样的变化，你可以跟踪这一点。我认为关于社交媒体的很多对话，从你给他们第一台iPad、第一次给他们第一部手机或让他们使用你的手机的那一刻起，每次他们想注册一个新的社交媒体网站时，都是进行另一次对话的好时机。这不是一次谈话，而是在不同年龄阶段的许多时期进行多次谈话。例如，当你即将第一次上初中时，当你即将第一次上高中时，你可能想制定哪些新规则？因为适合六年级的规则将不再是你为十年级设定的规则。
if they could monitor that more and be really clear about if this is if this is a parent approved, you know, signing up and to have real, you know, accountability in that. Because a lot of times there's these long user agreements that people, you know, barely scan maybe when they sign up for the next app, the next site. And so I think if there were user-friendly language agreements, you know, user agreements that were for youth, you know, so they can understand what are the privacy, you know, considerations, what are they going to use with their data in the language that they could understand, you know, I think that would be one step to make sure that they, that they are protected in the kind of privacy and prevention of harassment sorts of concerns that parents have.
那时有更多的自主权，父母完全不知道的事情也更多。但如果你已经在他们身上灌输了你希望他们在网络世界中继续下去的价值观，并且你觉得他们能够以健康的方式处理自己，不过分担心发生的戏剧，并了解其背后的社交媒体素养、假新闻和所有这类事情，那么你会觉得你在漫长的讨论过程中尽到了自己的责任。所以我很好奇，是否有办法让这些社交媒体平台对年轻人更安全，
Do you think these companies are really motivated to do this, though? I mean, is there a way to get them to do it without having to establish? some sort of, I don't know, watchdog agency, some sort of federal regulators that are going to crack down. Yeah, I mean, they are a business and they have a, you know, a capitalist model, perhaps, you know. And so I think, I think there needs to be probably some kind of external regulation system, whether it's the government or some other board of overseers that understand the implications of this, you know, maybe people who are, you know, computer science program, ethical decision makers, psychologists, you know, people, therapists and educators and
特别是你正在研究的初中生。我只是在想，我们如何平衡制作和提供这些平台的公司的成功愿望与保护年轻人免受潜在危害？嗯，可能需要以更严格的态度去做的一件事是真正监控谁是你们网站上的人，他们到底多大？因为从技术上讲，你必须年满13岁，但绕过这些年龄要求并输入一个假的出生日期是如此容易。我认为如果公司能做到这一点，那将最符合其用户的利益，
parents, a nice sort of board of overseers to understand this process because they don't have financial conflicts of interest like businesses and advertisers who may only care about the headcount, they only care about the number of clicks, they only care about how many ads can be put within this YouTube segment and how many times can be placed ads, you know, within this five-minute video. So they have a whole other set of concerns. And another thing is that that COPA requirement of age 13 is based on a federal regulatory body that isn't necessarily researchers. It's not based on research. And that's why I have this NIH grant. That's part of the reason why we wanted to do it with middle schoolers to understand this vulnerable age of, you know,
如果他们能够更多地监控这一点，并明确这是否是父母批准的注册，并在其中拥有真正的问责制。因为很多时候，人们在注册下一个应用程序或网站时，几乎只扫一眼这些漫长的用户协议。因此，我认为如果存在用户友好的语言协议，即针对青年的用户协议，这样他们就能了解隐私注意事项是什么，他们将如何使用他们的数据，并使用他们能够理解的语言，我认为这将是确保他们受到父母所关心的隐私和预防骚扰问题保护的一步。
anywhere between nine, nine to 13 when they're signing up for social media for the first time, you know, what are the implications of 10 versus 12 versus 14, you know, is there a sweet spot of when is, does it really not matter anymore? If you hit this age, then, then you're good to go. Or if this, if there's a critical age in which, in which, you know, maybe you shouldn't go any, any younger than this because X, Y, Z might happen. It's a longitudinal study. So we still don't have all the answers that we want to, you know, tell the listeners today about. And we look forward to being able to share that, but that's definitely the kind of research that needs to be happening at this very critical age group. And then what's the practical application of your work when it's
不过，你认为这些公司真的有动力这样做吗？我的意思是，有没有办法让他们在不必建立某种监督机构、某种将要进行打击的联邦监管机构的情况下做到这一点？是的，我的意思是，他们是一家企业，也许他们有资本主义模式。因此，我认为，可能需要某种外部监管系统，无论是政府还是其他理解这些影响的监督委员会，可能是计算机科学专业的人、道德决策者、心理学家、治疗师、教育工作者和
done? Do you make it available to the social media companies, or does it just go to NIH? I mean, how does it get used and translated into something that will make a difference? Yes, yes. That's the perennial, you know, sort of dilemma of all researchers who get funded and dissemination and translation to the different audiences in which it needs to go to, whether it's, you know, policymakers, marketing executives, to computer programmers, to the general public and families, you know, educators. There's so many different pieces to the messages that we want to convey, that it needs to be its own project.
父母，一个很好的监督委员会来理解这个过程，因为他们没有像企业和广告商那样只关心人数、只关心点击次数、只关心在这个YouTube片段中可以放置多少广告以及在这个五分钟的视频中可以放置多少次广告的财务利益冲突。因此，他们有一套完全不同的担忧。另一件事是，13岁的COPA要求是基于不一定是研究人员的联邦监管机构。它不是基于研究的。这就是为什么我获得这个NIH拨款的原因。这也是我们想要对初中生进行研究的部分原因，以了解9岁到13岁之间注册社交媒体的这个脆弱年龄，
It's its own separate project, you know, with a big team of people to try to advocate for different audiences to be able to find things. in ways that they can reach it. So things like webinars, things like, you know, doing podcasts, doing open access publications whenever possible so that the general public can click on your article and not just be behind a firewall where you have to pay if you're part of an institution,
10岁与12岁与14岁的区别是什么，是否存在一个最佳点，到达这个年龄是否真的不再重要？如果你达到了这个年龄，那么你就可以放心使用了。或者是否存在一个关键年龄，如果在这个年龄之下，你也许不应该再年轻了，因为可能会发生X、Y、Z。这是一项纵向研究。所以我们仍然没有我们今天想要告诉听众的所有答案。我们期待能够分享这些，但这绝对是在这个非常关键的年龄段需要进行的那种研究。然后，你的工作在完成后有什么实际应用？你是把它提供给社交媒体公司，还是只给NIH？我的意思是，它是如何被使用并转化为能产生影响的成果的？
you know, having a YouTube channel, you know, ready for the different disseminations of your pieces, having like these five-minute, you know, sort of video abstracts of your, pieces to reach more people who don't have the time or the inclination to read academic articles, you know, from front to back. These are all conversations that we need to have. We need to have more convenings and think tanks of people of many different backgrounds that could, you know, chip away at all the different ways that we can help, you know, families and youth, use social
是的，是的。这是所有获得资助的研究人员的永恒困境，即如何传播和转化给需要它的不同受众，无论是决策者、营销高管、计算机程序员，还是普通公众、家庭和教育工作者。我们想要传达的信息有太多不同的部分，它需要成为它自己的项目。
media in healthier ways. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Sharmerman. I think what you're doing is really important. I appreciate the work that you. you are doing to keep our kids safe. Thank you so much, and I can wait to continue this conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
它是一个独立的项目，拥有一个庞大的团队来努力为不同的受众倡导，以便能够以他们可以接触到的方式找到事情。因此，像网络研讨会、播客、尽可能进行开放获取出版物这样的一般公众可以点击你的文章，而不只是被挡在需要付费才能访问机构的防火墙后面，
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiant. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拥有一个准备好传播你的作品不同部分的YouTube频道，拥有像这五分钟的视频摘要这样的作品片段，以接触更多没有时间或倾向于从头到尾阅读学术文章的人。这些都是我们需要进行的对话。我们需要进行更多的集会和智囊团，由具有许多不同背景的人组成，他们可以为帮助家庭和青年以更健康的方式使用社交媒体的所有不同方法出谋划策。